ça les choux
dans le temps on pack réputé c'est que
vous voyez à bas prix 1 c'est là qu'on a
compris que l' aventure allait être
rendez vous voilà c'est pas mal il
souffle
[Musique]
bonjour le saviez vous en bourgogne
franche comté on aime construire la
région possède le plus grand nombre de
sites classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
c'est là que je vous emmène c'est en
bourgogne à la découverte de ces sites
aussi méconnu qu'insolite avec au
programme le survol de château en hélico
la découverte d'un village de hobbit et
la construction d'une cabane avec un pro
de la survie allez tout ça c'est ici
c'est maintenant c'est la china
[Musique]
notre exploration de l'architecturé en
bourgogne allait démarrer dans les airs
direction la vallée de l'ouche au sud
ouest de dijon pour avoir un point de
vue unique sur le patrimoine de la
région
rien de tel qu'un vol en hélicoptère
c'est ainsi que séverine gaudi
architecte des bâtiments de france
prenez place dans le robinson r44 de
xavier delattre un pilote chevronné
[Musique]
je
pour séverine arrivé dans la région il
ya quelques mois à peine ce vol allait
être son baptême mais surtout une
occasion unique d'observer sous une
autre perspective
un patrimoine d'exception
je propose là c'est de faire un circuit
en partant de darois par la valley la
vallée de l'ouche
ici on a le château de l'antenne sur
notre droite la côte d'or de manière
générale est très riche en monuments
historiques et avec un grand nombre de
châteaux pour effectuer tous plus fous
les uns que les autres
or là on rentre dans le début de la
vallée de l'ouche donc on voit le canal
est louche
il doit son de jcs la pause
[Musique]
séverine et xavier approche de
châteauneuf-en-auxois où se dresse
fièrement un château médiéval
particulièrement bien conservé l'un des
tout premiers et ont fait l'objet d'une
protection au titre des monuments
historiques
mais c'est impressionnant de voir de
cette manière là parce que j'ai
tellement comprend bien ce lieu
stratégique et pourquoi est ce qu'ils
ont construit aussi un château médiéval
que le château a été construit au 12e
siècle il avait aussi choisi par rapport
à ce rôle défensif on voit justement le
château sur son propre toit rocheuses
avec quelques la gauche la partie la
plus ancienne correspond en fait aux
doublons qui a été construite au
deuxième siècle
on remarque aussi que c'est ainsi qu'il
ya beaucoup évolué comme je voulais
d'initiales monde et brun un bâti un
donjon du 12e siècle qui en fait a été
complété au xiiie siècle par la
construction de tours où on aperçoit
encore aujourd'hui les éléments sont
assez intéressant quand on quand on les
observe parce que finalement ça permet
de comprendre la logique d'évolution des
sites castro et notamment les relations
pour pouvait avoir entre ce site et le
village
[Musique]
tarbes se dirige vers le village de
commarin permanent de château cos marin
rien château qui est détenu depuis 200
ans dans la même famille chaque
propriétaire auront ou non où il
intervient on intervient selon le style
de son époque est typiquement le château
de cobra on est un très bel exemple de
ce qu'il faut s'imaginer que ce château
jusqu'au 16e siècle ressembler à celui
de châteauneuf rogatoire précédemment
ouah on avait un système pas vraiment de
château avec les tours avec la mûre de
quantification c'est seulement à partir
du xviie siècle que les propriétaires
auront remis au goût du jour et du style
de l'époque avec up proposition
architecturale classique très régulière
13 ordonnance et le système de touva
également largement évolué ou au xixème
siècle en fait on
élargissez douvres a créé un effet de
miroir d'eau qui rend finale on la
perspective actuelle jacobins ralenti
avec la réflexion qu'on peut avoir du
château dans ce miroir d'eau le bâti
ancien est une vraie richesse dans la
région
[Musique]
et quand il est rénové avec audace il se
transforme en art
[Musique]
pour nous en rendre compte nous sommes
allés à nuits saint georges au sein de
ce vignoble mythique se trouve la
cuverie tout juste rénovée du domaine
faible et c'est sans nul doute l'une des
plus belles de bourgogne
[Musique]
une rénovation ambitieuse au cours de
laquelle se sont rencontrés la
créativité de l'architecte chalonnais
gilles gauvin et les désirs d'ouverture
sur le vignoble de la famille fais les
visites guidées en compagnie d'erwan
propriétaire du domaine et de la jeune
architecte bérengère jolivet c'est
vraiment ce que j'adore maintenant avec
ce bâtiment c c c c couverture cette vue
le la respiration que ça donne même
visuellement on a créé une ouverture et
oui aussi
architecturalement on a à errer un petit
peu ce bâtiment en fait on sait on s'est
retrouvé avec avec une cour qui était un
peu vide alors certes qui était ouvert
sur le paysage mais un peu vide et il
fallait il faire il fallait trouver
comment la bise et donc on est parti sur
une coursive et je trouve que le
résultat et le résultat est vraiment
très très réussie
cette coursive fraîchement créé donne à
l'ensemble un air de cloître cistercien
un clin d'oeil assumer à l'histoire
religieuse et architectural de la région
si les extérieurs du bâtiment sont
étonnants l'intérieur de la cuverie
l'est tout autant
ici un soin tout particulier a été porté
sur le travail des volumes et de la
lumière
ce qui est sympa ce qu'on retrouve là on
retrouve la vue sur la ville depuis ici
j'aime bien être ici on retrouve cette
vue à travers une porte et c'est assez
magistrale
alors certains disent que c'est ça fait
une cathédrale
en fait l'idée d' idée au départ c'était
c'était plus dans d'en faire une gare on
s'est inspiré un peu de la gare du nord
bon et c'est vrai que ça ressemble
autant à une cathédrale finalement avec
la gare du nord c'est ça qui est rigolo
c'est de voir qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qui passe par les jaunes qu'est ce que
ça leur communiquent leur donne comme
sensation les pierres blanches de
comblanchien et les poutres métalliques
en référence à eiffel confère à la
cuverie d'erwan un aspect industriel
grandiose et surprenant l'endroit sert
de lieu de réception mais aussi bien sûr
à vinifier du pinot noir exclusivement
donc ça c'est un peu le c'était un peu
le clou de cette cette rénovation qu'on
y pense un peu triste parce que
finalement c'est c'est la plus belle
pièce du du bâtiment qu'on utilise
finalement que trois semaines par an
c'est ça alors moi ce que j'aime
particulièrement quand on est dans cette
année dans cet endroit c'est que on
retrouve le on retrouve à travers la
grande baie vitrée
le fus le paysage qu'on voyait tout à
l'heure et le fait qu'ils soient
encadrés dans cette danse est biden lui
donne une autre dimension pour
l'impression de voir un peu une carte
postale de la bourde fait ça avec comme
sa graphie avec tout le temps à nos
activités d'ailleurs on la pauvre l'a
pas fait exprès pour la journée mais
finalement on voit on a deux nos
vignerons qui sont en train de tailler
la vigne juste juste en face de justice
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est que
maintenant aujourd'hui grâce à cette
ouverture on retourne fait le lien entre
la vinicole et les viticole qu'on
n'avait pas avant c'était de tout le but
de cette rénovation
prochaine étape st gervais surcouche en
retraite village situé sur un domaine
entouré de bocages et des bois se trouve
une construction étonnante le nid aux
étoiles un gîte tout confort perchée sur
pilotis à l'origine du projet il y à
joël nottaris un ingénieur touche à tout
longtemps spécialisé dans l'ébénisterie
haut de gamme et l' architecture
d'intérieur
dans son atelier il propose des cours de
sculpture peinture travail du bois ou du
métal bref c'est ce qu'on appelle un
passionné je me suis mis à mon compte en
tant qu et bénisse pendant 15 ans
j'avais plus trop de temps pour la
création et puis pas trop de temps non
plus pour pour faire ce que j'aime ça
dit rencontrer les gens donc en fait
j'ai trouvé le bon mic mac c'est de le
faire de la formation d'apprendre ce que
je sais faire et puis de recevoir des
gens pour les les aider à mener à bien
leurs projets artistiques ou artisanales
les stagiaires que joël accueil peuvent
dormir sur place en campant dans le
vaste parc de la propriété
mais depuis peu ils peuvent également
profiter du nid aux étoiles une
structure d'hébergement insolite sur
pilotis pensé et conçu par le maître des
lieux
j'ai retrouvé une verrière d'une
orangerie d'occasions et puis gelé tout
adapté pour l'intégrer dans le dans le
concept
on est à la fois ce côté un peu anciens
sympa mais réadapter dans le dans
l'ensemble du projet
grâce à sa toiture en verre et à sa
situation géographique loin de toute
pollution lumineuse
le gîte de joël est l'endroit idéal pour
passer une nuit romantique sous les
étoiles
c'est aussi un lieu privilégié pour les
astronomes amateurs
à l'instar de grégory venu tout droit
d'alsace ce jour là afin d'observer les
astres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ouais très bien je vais installer
pour la terrière ils ont droit à ces
sacrés matos non et alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut voir à tuer carrément des
planètes des étoiles dénoncé une note
plutôt pour la peau pour les nébuleuses
c'est à dire les pouponnières d'étoilés
là où les étoiles naissent et là je suis
en train de juger ajouté soir la
niveleuse de l'âme et j'ai déjà fait
plusieurs heures de pose là je vais
continuer ce soir pour avoir une dizaine
d'heure de pause 10 heures de pause
ouais même plus là car plus on pose
longtemps sur un objet plus on aura de
détail 10 heures le soir pour avoir une
image faut déjà être adressé de la
patience mais ça va c'est un peu comme
c'est un peu comme monter un truc 25 ans
faut être patient ça prend du temps
ouais c'est tout c'est plein d'énergie
mais au final ça fait un truc choque moi
en tout cas je dirais bien pour pour
faire ce à quoi ses bas en fait il ya
très peu de pollution lumineuse dans
quoi en fait j'ai regardé via une carte
qui s'appelle avec ce qui indique que ou
est-ce qu'il ya moins de pollution
lumineuse c'est en général comme ça que
je choisis mes mais j ai il est inhérent
pas mal ici
mais même sans lunettes tu as des ciels
étoilés hallucinant ici la verrière et
c'est génial parce que moi j'ai jamais
le temps vraiment de regarder le ciel
quand je suis à la photo je me suis
concentré de tomate en soirée après une
fois que s'élance et dépose une fois que
ces cadres énoncés je vais monter là je
vais m'allonger à éteindre les lumières
et puis moi je vais regarder ciel étoilé
a travaillé à fait ça la soirée
s'annonçait longue pour grégory
l'astronome amateur
mais sans nul doute à l'aller être
confortable grâce aux nuits insolites
construit par joël vous savez ce qu'on
dit la nuit porte conseil
[Musique]
et des conseils en matière d'habitat
nous allions en avoir direction le
morvan à quelques kilomètres de saulieu
nous avions rendez-vous en forêt avec
eric alexandre ce guide de haute
montagne
allez nous dévoiler le secret pour
construire un abri une expérience
insolite où les bases architectural
doivent être respectées quelles que
soient les conditions météo
yannick victor on y va ah ben tiens
on va récupérer ça aussi
ok on va s'installer la verront sur les
piétiner si on va dormir là tu vois là
on a une fourche une fourche ici n'étiez
pas mal certes ici à vous de voir
on pourra faire la poutre maîtresse donc
je sais pas il n'y a pas besoin de toi
victor tu peut tailler les chevrons
qu'on va mettre qu'on va poser
et puis j'ai repéré l'an venant il ya
des deux sapins sens propre il y en a un
qui est juste derrière
on va récupérer des branches de sapin
pour isoler du sol celui là tu renvoies
on va l'abattre
on va le dire était en morceaux de parce
qu'on va les mettre dans ce sens là tu
vois les députés ont baissé d'un mètre
et puis plus à ça fera le central tapis
de sol est maintenant bien mais un
maximum de manches
d'accord ok on y va comme ça un abri
qu'il est il adapté toujours pas au
terrain c'est pas la peine de mort soit
quelque chose d'énorme site a déjà des
points d'appui naturel donc un point
d'appui naturel ça peut être un tas de
bois calé j'ai empilé ça peut être un
cru dans la falaise sur laquelle tu veux
appuyer les toits non claude économise
du temps de l'énergie
après c'est comme une structure de
maison et a toujours des poteaux
porteurs toujours une panne au dessus
qui va serait-elle pour s'appuyer de
chevron et puis ensuite par la
couverture la couverture étanche au
sommet tu viens tu la fais avec ce que
tu trouves sur le terrain
de toute façon c'est toujours très
compliqué un petit peu parce que j'aime
ça qu'il faut privilégier des endroits
déjà naturellement abriter cette façon
que t'es pas les normes barnum à
construire c'est point principal c'est
très libre ou chimique
rassure toi tu as vu il est beau tu es
beau tu es bien on couvre bien comme ça
et puis on rentre dedans pour pas que ça
sent trahie et qu'un coup de vent
d'accord voilà bien faire pénétrer plus
on pourchasse on roule pas ok ça paraît
bien
il nous en faut encore trois fois comme
ça trois fois ok l'histoire c'est que tu
vas l'intérieur j'ai 30 ans intérieur
garde il ya des gouttes d'eau tu vois
mieux que là parce que là tu vois un
droit mais tu vois regarde tous les
endroits où il ya des gouttes d'eau au
foot ou combler avec des branches
techniques pour combler avec les
branches en fait les l'histoire c'est de
bien voir garde ses 2 les maillots
horizontal et vertical la pressante sont
verticales on va essayer de l'émail et
récents d'accord d'accord on peut comme
les feuilles de palmier de bambous
géants donc on a les traits c'est comme
du com comme une chaise entrer certains
pareil et puis il vous faudra encore des
mois que je sapin pour isoler une seule
parce que principe ses branches de sapin
ronde un matelas et branches de sapin
mais vrai j'ai zappé amiable tu vois il
faut de la petite branche comme ça
faisait si longtemps divers thèmes qui
déroule plus d'une heure de travail
allait être nécessaire a hérité à son
groupe pour construire un abri digne de
ce nom
étant donné la météo l'effort était mis
sur l'isolation de la construction mais
pour passer une nuit au sec et au chaud
il restait encore à faire du feu un défi
de taille à relever une fois la nuit
tombée
en attendant direction boon et ses
environs deux autres aventuriers
s'étaient donné rendez vous dans une
forêt romain et thibault sont des
passionnés durbec ce l'exploration
urbaine une activité très en vogue qui
consiste à visiter des lieux abandonnés
comme des usines des maisons ou des
hôtels dans leur viseur ce jour-là un
ancien parc musée dont nous tairons
volontairement le nom et l'emplacement
[Musique]
va falloir qu'on se croise un grillage
on va voir trouver un trou pour pouvoir
passer comme on peut à bon droit yare
c'est un gars de la regarde là celle ci
c'est pas parfait c'est même nickel
j'aurais pu dire yes on va passer ici on
va beaucoup parler
ouais tiens pas fait le ton matos tu vas
passer en premier je fais bien attention
et gaffe si j'accroche bien l'arbre je
suis comme tout le temps mais comme ça
au pire au bal à zogona plateau on peut
voir que je pense que lui il a du crâne
et à dubrulle et je pense avec le temps
du coup on va lui par le bas monsieur on
va essayer de faire le tour du bâtiment
vert ale entre ouverte ça devrait être
bon en en faisant un passage
ce que j'espère up aller
hu
c'est chouette un parent garde aux
cadavres
attention ça jamais si une alarme coin
détecteur de mouvement peut se passer et
tu sais
c'est vrai que l'urbex s'interdit quoi
mais bon après nous on sait ce qu'on
fait on sait les risques encourus
vraiment si on a de quoi prouver qu'on a
rien dégrader dans lieu ça passe souvent
la première règle déjà ses ondes valent
rien dans le lieu important on dilue pas
l'adresse aussi et on ne tape pas on
dégrade rien dans lieux c'est vraiment
on visite comprend vidéo en photo comme
on veut vraiment ces 11 cas surya ont
des gars de rien je ferai ce qu'il veut
alors et si j'allais ya deux ans c'était
des gens tu as un peu comme ça bon là je
pense qu'avant il va avoir une
sûrement une représentation pareil pour
l'adjoint franchement ça reste et
timmins tout cas il ya que ça je pense
qu a été détériorée avec le temps je
pense enlevés ils ont même retiré je
dirais retire parce que c'est du plat
donc ça ne part pas comme ça comme si
est bien c'est que l'ue est tellement
respecté ici que les gens vont pas
forcer les portes
waouh
ouah c'est immense sapin fois que nous
les urbex heures les vrais sur vaccins
on n'est pas là pour dégrader les lieux
au contraire on est là pour l'histoire
des lieux on est là vraiment pour
découvrir un lieu par exemple la com de
lyon on est aujourd'hui
moi j étais venu quand il reste trois
ans donc voilà de le revoir un peu à
l'abandon comme ça je me dis purée ça
fait bizarre c'est un lieu voilà qui qui
me rappelle un peu la nostalgie comme on
dit aman voilà beaucoup de personnes
font de l'urbex aussi pour revoir les
lieux qui qui voyait quand il était plus
jeune et qui est maintenant sont à
l'abandon
si on m'avait dit d'aller voir un gars
comme ça aujourd'hui je n'ai pas y
croire nous laissant thibault et romain
poursuivre leur exploration de ce
bâtiment du passé peu commun nous
retournons dans le morvan où la pluie
tombe toujours pour nos spécialistes de
la survie faire du feu est plus que
jamais indispensable
alors moi je parle jamais sans son petit
morceau de bois sont des morceaux de
bois qui sont secs de telle façon qu'on
puisse au but faire un petit plancher et
puis on a démarré le feu maintenant avec
aucun matériel un petit peu spécial ces
domaines de faire ça c'est super rien
par tout de suite rien il faut un tout
petit rouleau ça tu vois il faut juste
que la file juste à pile tu assures à
ferraille ça fait rien
cette crépitent c'est pas mal du tout le
fait d'être en pleine nature
ça ça ressources il ya vraiment là je
pense qu'on peut se ressourcer mais
sachez aussi du rap a pas trente six
heures trente six heures en pleine forêt
ça donne un réel effort on arrive à
discerner si tout le monde participe à
l'effort commun de confort il viendrait
que tout le monde y participe
donc voilà ce que ça réveille avec le
fait de d'être de pâte dans la foule de
tous les jours puis de vivre quelque
chose d'un petit peu insolite sens pour
ça soit très loin de de la nature ou
très loin des villages ou très loin de
l'idée cette ressource et puis de faire
une immersion en pleine nature
et ça c'est mieux que tout ça du tout
parce qu'on vit avec des choses simples
savoir fabriquer un abri et allumer un
feu cela peut s'avérer très utile mais
pour cette nuit le groupe a une autre
idée en tête
dans cette forêt au bord du lac de
chamboux yannick a créé un véritable
village fantastique unique en france des
maisons de hobbits tout droit sortis de
l'imaginaire de tolkien des gîtes
extraordinaire où il fait bon se reposer
et se réchauffer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hu au revoir
[Musique]
alors voilà la maison des spots way
extraordinaire fait-on bois cordé sur
les murs et les ont publiées avec de la
chaux d'accord et la tétée morceaux de
bois ont une profonde c'est qu'on en
train de construire ils font 50 locaux
et celle ci c'était la première donc on
sait 33 donc c'était petit but choletais
a pris plusieurs essences d'arbres voit
la plupart c'est dû être rychen way
hêtre chêne charme et là c'est un charme
celui à sa ceinture at il ya un gros
tuyau dans ta quoi dans ta maison d'un
salon salle à manger là d'accord et puis
le coin chambre avec la la baignoire la
baignoire c'est une balle onge de
viticulteurs
[Musique]
les plans que j'ai vu comment tu t'es
venu pas en fait y'a pas de plan de
deux maisons comme celle ci c'est au fur
et à mesure qu'on montait car si on
faisait ça si on faisait ça puis avec
les artisans aussi qui ont travaillé
avec nous et eux ils ont bu plein
d'idées pour faire tiens si on sortait
des bouts de bois plus long et observe
une étagère d'agrès faire aussi des
bandes furent une table basse est
vraiment le bois c'est génial comment ça
t'est venue l'idée de faire ça ici dans
le morvan
on voulait créer un lieu à nous pour
pouvoir créer des choses donc des
spectacles aussi
enfin surtout inviter des gens les
accueillir un lieu vraiment à part
différents et puis tout ce qui est
fantastique basse et c'est bien ça ça
excite un peu le rêve un peu
l'imagination et c'est ce qui nous a
beaucoup plu et surtout dans le morvan
bas peut-être je pars en val de saône ou
ou ailleurs où c'est le plat en bresse
c'est magnifique mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas y'a pas les cailloux ya pas
les montagnes a pas cet aspect légende
parle du retour en plein dans le paysage
vivre dans l'habitat d'un semis homme ou
dans celui d'un magicien
tout est possible au domaine de la
pierre ronde l'imaginaire et le
fantastique n'attendent plus que vous
a encore une belle balade en bourgogne
allez je vous embrasse fort fort fort je
vous dis à la semaine prochaine un grand
merci encore pour votre fidélité
je vous embrasse
[Musique]